the cdc's announcement about not having
to wear your mask when you're outdoors
when biking walking running may have
come
as a relief for many of us but there are
still some specific guidelines in
regards to that
eight news now reporter victoria saha
joining us live to break it down for us
victoria
hey brian for a majority of the pandemic
we've been told to wear our mask and
although you might think it's time to
ditch the mask
you want to hold on to it even if you're
vaccinated or not
when you're on the las vegas strip
you're surrounded by people from all
over
making it hard to not wear a mask even
with the cdc's new outdoor guidelines
the cdc says you can now go outside
without your mask
unless you're surrounded with a big
group of strangers
a few tourists we spoke with say they
aren't letting their guard down
even though they're vaccinated still
wearing our mask
all the time and probably still will in
big crowds
because there's so many that will not
get it fascinated or have not been
while others feel a little more relaxed
it's going to be
a little less what i'm actually doing
and more the comfort
because there's kind of been an air of
fear being vaccinated it feels like a
layer of defense the new outdoor mask
rules
do have some specific guidelines though
the cdc says fully vaccinated or not you
don't have to wear your mask if you're
gathering outdoors with other people
who are fully vaccinated another
guideline though if you are
unvaccinated and you know you'll be
meeting up with other
unvaccinated people outdoors you will
still have to keep your mask
on president biden says these new
guidelines should be another encouraging
factor to get vaccinated
as for here in nevada our mask mandate
is still in place
and the governor's office says they will
announce any changes
though these new guidelines are for
being outdoors only the cdc is still
recommending everyone to still continue
to wear your mask
when you're inside public places
reporting live from the strip victoria
saha
8 news now